there's the situation there are dark
forces at play the deep state globalists
bill nighy and this program will oppose
them at all costs but just like Lee
Harvey Oswald I can't do it alone we
have we have an incredible team of
citizen journalists you may already know
them if you've been a loyal listener to
the oppo radio network or watched our
YouTube videos or subscribe to our anti
mainstream snapchat stories and now
they're all here covering the stories
you need to know about starting with our
resident First Amendment champions and
social provocateurs Josh sharp and Erin
Jackson and here they are they're all
read Berkeley where free speech week was
just cancelled guys what's going on
Jordan free speech week may have been
canceled but we are not going anywhere
because the Constitution guarantees
Americans the right to free speech and
it also guarantees an audience for that
yeah preferably on TV maybe radio we'd
also take streaming either way this
crinkly old bitch lets us say whatever
yeah you don't have to agree with it but
you do have to accept it also follow us
on social right keep playing guys
there's so much to cover here as you as
you may know many NFL players have been
taking a knee during our precious
national anthem for an update we have
citizen journalist Laura gray in her
living room Laura Jordan I feel attacked
is there anything more violent than a
non-violent act of civil disobedience
those knees don't belong on the ground
they belong out on the field smashing
into groins and faces yes athletes are
there to get concussions not to make us
think exactly progressives love freedom
of thought so much what about freedom
from thought I wanted to spend my whole
Sunday thinking I'd watch baseball yes
obviously the opposition is a lot more
than just a half-hour of nightly
television over an opposition radio our
resident expert Kobe lebih is mid-show
breaking down current events let's
listen in because which is what a
pumpkin technically is but to get back
to this story the Washington Post is all
over what's causing these hurricanes
tons of coverage to words you won't see
in any of their articles Maxine Waters
why not let's back up and talk eugenics
for a second yes okay now you don't hear
that kind of talk from vetted sources
let's go to the coal Thurman the coal
turbines at a trump rally waiting for it
to start Nicole why does mainstream
media insist that all black people
support Democrats Jordan I'm voted for
Obama okay he never did anything for me
Obamacare was bull all right I'll get my
health care from the Affordable Care Act
yes
they call personally I bet you get a lot
more respect from Trump than Obama the
second I walk into any Trump rally is
like the room stops all right
like I am basically an instant celebrity
and then Trump staff just brings me
right here behind the podium every time
I'll tell you what I will tell you what
all of my black friends are so jealous
that they don't even talk to me anymore
but you know where I'm on the Trump
train boot world yes will whoa indeed
next we go to Tim bolts in Alabama
watching tomorrow's Republican Senate
primary between Luther strange and Roy
Moore who's looking good to him
neither one of them Jordan we need a
candidate further to the right than both
of these guys Tim they're both pretty
darn conservative Roy Moore has
conflated homosexuality with bestiality
I can't get behind more until he comes
out against true bestiality which is
when animals have sex with other animals
imagine a Jordan a dog having relations
with another dog that's how dogs
reproduce Tim what are you a Democrat
okay fine keep us posted team what a
team
[Music]